from a recent trip to Japan my home
country I brought back a little present
it's a traditional toy a Japanese story
called kami who Sam
which means paper balloon and as you can
see it's a balloon made of paper and
there's a hole in there yeah
so the where are you inflate this paper
by the moon when you wash it is to blow
into this hole and make it rounder okay
but this another way to make it rounder
you can squash it and then you can start
tossing it around you hit it from all
sides at random oops now when you hit
something don't you have the impression
that you are denting it and therefore
making it less and less round and you're
denting it right from both sides but
look at what's happening as I toss it
and hit it from all sides I'm doing
completely handily you can eat it quite
hard what was suitable to a little
crumpled it's now getting rounder and
rounder and becoming more and more
spherical and look I ended up with a
round sphere so this is a really strange
way of making something round by denting
it repeatedly from all sides how does
this trick work I think the key to this
behavior which all Japanese children
know instinctively is really in the
following behavior over the balloon when
i swivel it to a little crumpled watch
what happens when i release it you see
it starts fighting its way back at least
initially it doesn't inflate all the way
back of course but it has some memory
and he wants to come back to where it
started it fights its way back as I said
that's that's an interesting question
and I have to think about this so let's
imagine the following toy model let's
say that you have a state of this
balloon which is crumpled on both sides
on the left as well as on the right and
I'm going to strike this balloon at this
moment pass from the left let's say what
happens to a good approximation I think
is that decide that you hit gets over
crumpled because you I just did you know
you introduce a lot of compost I don't
know how but the other side gets puffed
out literally because there is this
force which pushes it right word but you
see then something interesting happens
is that fighting back effect means that
the left side which was over crumpled
starts fighting back
so it starts expanding to roughly the
degree of ring cleanness that they had
in the beginning whereas the right hand
side stays puffed out so per this cycle
you see what happened is that I increase
the overall smoothness a little bit the
other side which got puffed out whereas
this side that I over wrinkled
fought back by itself so if you keep
hitting it from all sides gradually you
are making the thing round and Rhonda
[Music]
so let's plot the evolution of the
volume against time and let's say in
time I'm hitting the balloon at various
regular intervals it doesn't have the
irregular intervals okay so the volume
of the balloon starts like this and as
soon as I hit it of course
instantaneously I suddenly decrease the
volume I just shrivel it's a hit
gives you this lip but then the thing
fights back yeah this is the fight back
and then the next hit will decrease the
volume and they need to fight back fight
back and so and gradually it asymptotes
or it approaches this spherical shape
from below like this so it never becomes
completely spherical but it grows like
that so I think there is a process of
grow shrink grow shrink grow string zig
zag zig zag and then goes back then
that's why you can do this strange thing
of hitting it or denting it repeatedly
and yet the result outcome is that it
becomes round and round okay this will
probably take a long time
behave exactly the same way
whereas 45 degrees off